so
one fascinating thing you said is uh
that blew my mind and we went right past
it uh which is the
temperature is a really powerful
like if you were to think about the ways
that different parts of the body
different systems in the
body would communicate with each other
temperature
would be a really good one and that just
i mean maybe it's obvious but it kind of
blew my mind just now that
yeah these systems are all distributed
right and they have to kind of they're
not actually sending signals but they're
coordinating they need
some sort of universal thing to look at
in order to coordinate and temperature
is a nice one to
to uh to build around and that way
you could control the behavior of all
these different systems by controlling
the temperature
right if it's attractive to think of a
mechanism where this
master circadian clock secretes a
peptide or something that goes and
locks to receptors in all the cells and
gets it just right but that leaves far
too much room for
variability binding affinities cells in
a lot of
parts of our body are at different
stages of maturation they're turning
over
liver cells and so forth and for
instance our we have a clock in our gut
and in our liver
such that if we were just take out your
liver and put it on a table
and just look at the expression of these
genes it would be in a 24-hour
oscillation on its own it's independent
but something has to entrain them and
keep them all synchronized and so it's
not obvious that it would be temperature
takahashi's great gift to biology was to
show that
all the stuff coming out of this master
circadian clock
at the end of the day that's a weird
statement no pun intended
at the end at the end of the day and the
night at the um
at the end of the story it all boils
down to making sure that the temperature
of tissues
oscillates in the same fashion that's
blowing my mind and thinking
like what other mechanism could possibly
exist
to create that kind of oscillation well
you're
you're rushing it's cold in russia for a
lot of the year the hibernation signal
in certain
animals is a remarkable signal there are
peptides secreted from this very same
clock
that in animals like ground squirrels or
bears
they go into a kind of a torpor where
everything reproduction
metabolism everything is reduced while
they're in their cave they don't
actually stay asleep
all of winter that's a myth um and they
actually do these very
um dramatic and periodic arousals from
hibernation where they just shake and
shake and shake it looks like a seizure
and then they go back under into the
torpor
that's from a peptide that's released
but that's different because that's
about
shutting down the whole system it's
clear that having these very regular
oscillations every 24 hours is essential
for everything from
metabolism to reproduction
you